all right everybody it is time for
drew's news
and with me at the desk he'll news
non-stop until he drops it's rossi ross
matthews yes i will i live for it hi
everybody hi
well first up we're going to beautiful
lake como shall we everybody oh yes
italy where they shot the high fashion
movie of the season house of gucci
villa balbiano was the actual home of
the gucci patriarch aldo gucci and now
vogue reports that you can rent it on
airbnb say what i know
they're offering one lucky guest the
chance to stay for a night for the price
of one thousand one hundred and thirty
three dollars check out these photos it
was built in the late 16th century
hosted wild society parties in the 17th
century and today it's decked out with
antique furnishings and art bought at
sotheby's
why one person ross why couldn't you get
like a group to like split the bill and
party that house is so big
raw thoughts yeah i did the math right
so 1 133
if you get a group of 10 people divide
it carry the one that's 113 and 30 cents
a person okay
and i'll tell you
if you are like a house of gucci kind of
person on a house a tj maxx budget
that's what you gotta do
and that's how i kick it i mean did you
i saw the movie i went uh thanksgiving
morning i went to the theater i did it
gaga oh girl you did not disappoint an
emotional rollercoaster three hours long
but
totally worth it you must see it i
really want to see it i'm just i'm very
excited and gaga every single second of
every single day i'm gaga for gaga
everything everything everything it's
gorgeous and this place is gorgeous and
oh i'll be staying there one day all
right anyone want to come with yeah i do
okay good
we'll all split it all right next up if
you're looking for a fresh new cut for
the holidays we've got an old hairstyle
that's making a comeback so picture this
if a bob and a pixie had a baby it would
be a
bixie
and in bixy in style reports the bixi
well it's back and it's bolder than ever
we can take a look we have uh some
celebrities are doing it florence pugh
just gave herself a chop gabrielle union
posted this and said short hair don't
care i love her too
and we also love anne hathaway who just
took it short and tousled
i love her now drew in the 90s uh you
had it was like the golden age of the
bixie and you were the first queen right
do we have some pictures look oh yeah
but tell me about these ones these
dixies well every single one of them
i can tell you honestly is because i
fried my hair off by too much color
really absolutely that's why like your
bleach
no
i mean yes
but you're you're going to lose your
hair period anyone who thinks they're
going to mess with a lot of bleach i
went from black to purple to red to this
okay and if somebody at home is thinking
should i do a bixie what advice would
you give them
i would say
probably dye your hair and go crazy
first because you're end up you're going
to end up cutting it off anyway so play
before you have to lose it yeah while
it's long just get dirty with it just
like the one from whip it i had these
amazing black ends around the whole hair
we took like a ruler and did black dye
around this blonde white hair and it's
one of my favorite hairdos that i've
ever had in my life here's the thing
don't take it too seriously be playful
and then you'll get you know comfortable
because you've done everything and tried
it and i think it's important to
experiment with style get uncomfortable
and i will say this all the haircuts
that i ever had that i thought were like
lame-o at the time or i wasn't into i
look back and i really like the way i
look every single one every single
haircut oh god oh god there's probably
there's got to be one that you're like
oh i thought you were going to show
something no i wouldn't do that
i was like oh my god
right now i don't know i just say play
and the thing that i know the most
is that
you probably are gonna look back with so
much more love and enjoyment and
perspective than you have in that moment
so try to remember that when you're like
i don't like it i don't feel attractive
all that stuff like you will look back
at pictures and be like that was rob
that was rad yeah so be good to yourself
and this is advice i still need to make
for myself uh-huh but you've locked in
this is your look right
i'm done i'm done i'm done with hair so
i'm this is it i'm very comfortable and
i'm i'm just yeah i don't i have had too
many bleach
situations
all right you guys who's hungry
yeah so we're going to round out the
news menu with some dessert in today's
food news
all right
delish
reports do you all remember little
debbie you know little debbie right the
little dessert cakes yeah
i love little debbie little debbie is
the one woman i would consider dating
[Laughter]
well she has taken her classic
christmas tree cake and she's made that
into a holiday ice cream oh thank you
little debbie you've done it again it's
vanilla ice cream smashed together with
cake bits red icing and green sprinkles
and guess what
i made a phone call i said hey deb hook
me up and she did look we have it right
here this is a little debbie ice cream
this is what it looks like
i love little debbie can you see the
color of this if i just show the camera
look this is so holiday oh my god green
look at that oh my gosh okay hold on oh
my god
oh my god
oh god
did anybody pick that up what'd she say
a cake bite oh there's cake in there
thank you thank you so much there's cake
in here you guys run out and get the
little debbies it's everything in my car
thank you debbie i love you
[Music]